welcome back everybody this is the
Ingram angle special gratitude in the
age of Trump and for better and
sometimes for worse let's face it
talking politics at the Thanksgiving
table is practically as much of a
tradition as the turkey and the pumpkin
pie the mashed potatoes of gravy but
it's giving many of us some serious
heartburn because according to a new
poll from NPR and Marist 58% of
Americans say they are positively
dreading the prospect of discussing
politics during Thanksgiving that's up
five points from last year during the
aftermath of the election and thirty-one
percent say they're eager to do so
tomorrow but that's a 12 point plunge
from last year joining us now to analyze
two of my favorite people not they're
not just favorite colleagues the
favorite people here at Fox shannon
bream of course the anchor of the
brand-new 11 p.m. show on Fox and Bret
Baier who is wisely already in the balmy
weather home Naples Florida Brett I'm so
jealous here in Naples already I'm
sitting in your chair Brett I feel I
feel inadequate sitting in this chair
because this is your chair really but
I'm I'm just keeping it warm do you come
back it's it's great to see both of you
alright
Brett I want to start with you now Trump
is controversial the divide in the
country seems like it's worse than its
but ever before but I don't know if
that's even the case how do you avoid
this Maelstrom at the table what do you
do well I think it's a good question
because I think you have to be prepared
at the beginning you have to go in and
say you have other topics to talk about
entertainment sports the kids other
things I say stay away from Lavar ball
the wall of war right at all I think
those three things that rhyme you just
stay away from them but if it goes south
get to the place where you listen more
than you get heated you listen and calm
and maybe Brett you get when you're
listening you just chew and you make
sure you have a big mouth for food and
you're just chewing and nodding you know
it's like you're a lot of fights with
the family fights about other subjects
and Shannon when sometimes husbands will
say I'll just say yes dear yes dear they
don't go back they don't go back but it
is a little thorny because like a lot of
families on
and certainly in my family we have some
polar opposite views in my family like
some of my brothers are different
politically than I am and we just don't
we just don't talk about it we didn't
talk about anything but you want to play
a game of tic-tac-toe you know what it's
uncomfortable
listen I'll be with the inlaws this year
the Bream's and they do like to talk
politics they are there a lot of Fox
Watchers in there so thank God lucky you
listen I know exactly but the tricky
thing is they want to talk shop the
whole time and you know when you're away
from work you want to take it easy play
the tic-tac-toe stuff faced with
stuffing but they have a lot of
questions and I find that what I end up
doing is separating a lot of fact from
fiction because they'll hear a story or
see something on Facebook and I'm sort
of now deputized as the fake news buster
during these Thanksgiving meals and gets
to get get together because they want to
know what's actually been said or not
said I think one of the good strategies
I like Bret's but I think also something
I read that made sense to me instead of
talking about personality is like
president Trump like you know Hillary
Clinton whoever if you talk ideas or
policies that seems to work better for a
lot of families instead of getting into
the personalities which seems to
immediately put people on one side or
the other now Bret when you're down in
Florida and Naples is a lot of there are
a lot of Fox fans and Naples let's face
it it's a it's a wonderful place they
love you down there but it is true what
Shannon said when you want to get away I
know you're a big golfer you're big
athlete you want to be with your kids
you're beautiful with sons and wife but
you want to kind of get away but you are
pulled back into it right you just think
you're on the golf course seven-pole got
that perfect tee shot and then you're
well what do you think about this Brett
and what do you do all the time I know
what happens you guys to I mean I was at
the grocery store the other day somebody
stopped and talked to me about tax
reform and I would say how's the
pineapple so I think that listen when
you're talking politics I do think
Shannon's right to do broad topics and
start with the ones that you know a lot
of the different ideologies agree on
let's say corporate taxes killing Isis
figuring out a situation in North Korea
those are three good ones where most
left and right kind of agree now I want
to ask both of you your favorite
Thanksgiving memories out growing up and
I was saying this on the radio earlier
today that you know it's never about
stuff for presents for me
it's always about food music that my
mother used to play she's polish so she
always played this a record player we
had she played polish Christmas carols
and I kind of rolled my eyes oh my god I
can't wait here's something else but now
I get teared up when I hear some of the
some of that music today and it's the
smells of Thanksgiving and and just just
being together Brett what's one of your
favorite memories of growing up
Thanksgiving just being with your family
so two things one is my mom grew up
having turnips and I can't stand the
worst but every year we just made them
and they just sat there and it was just
my mom's weight them but but it was a
part of the transit tradition and then
the wishbone at the end pulling it apart
and which person got the bigger part of
the bone was got the wish to come true
and I remember that every year Shannon
you know what I I think the Bret's mom
should join the Bream's because they
like turnips also what is your taste I
don't know what the deal is but they
like it too they have no taste
I know but Emily salted you tried to
drown the actual tournament aced I don't
know they have the taste I don't I will
say my dad loved frying turkeys so you
know you get that of the bubbling hot
oil and they do the demonstrations every
year like don't do this you'll burn down
your whole house and kill everybody yeah
my dad loved the danger of making the
turkey that way so I always think about
that he also liked fireworks and blowing
stuff up and everything so I think the
fried turkey was just part of it now
Brett do you cook the turkey or you go
out to go out to dinner you get
something else we have officially gone
to the going out and having somebody
else do the dishes but now I do miss the
cooking thing that you know everybody
stands around and cooks but we have not
done it for a number of years well I
think the the what I like to hear about
is like the brining
people people calling in today about we
do Turkey over an open spit where
they're like really rotating the trick I
mean this turns into like a virtual
Olympics eat at this point you know it's
it's it's all day project it's fun most
thankful for this time here
you know honestly I'm a person of faith
and even through some tough times this
year just that I think God is good yeah
god is good Brett yeah I think health
and the big guy upstairs looking down on
us all and no matter how bad
you think things are gonna be we are all
resilient and we should be thankful for
that and ask ask for help ask ask for
God's help that's what I do every day
lord knows I can't do it by myself I'm
grateful for both of you thank you have
a wonderful Thanksgiving with your
families and thanks for everything you
do to keep the Fox viewers informed and
sometimes entertain let's face it you
can't be very funny Happy Thanksgiving
Brett Happy Thanksgiving